star française de la danse patrick
dupont a eu l'audace de relever un
redoutable défi abandonnant son statut
de danseur étoile à l'opéra de paris
dont il reste tout même l'invité
d'honneur patrick dupont en effet
accepté la direction artistique du
ballet français de nancy ce pour deux
ans c'était hier soir la première de son
premier spectacle
denis poncet l'avait rencontrée quelques
heures auparavant tout à fait heureux
dans ses nouvelles fonctions sur la
scène du théâtre de nancy
l'ex enfant prodige de la danse patrick
dupont patrick dupond 29 ans au zénith
de sa carrière des toiles internationale
et qui vient d'accepter le poste de
directeur artistique d'une des plus
dynamiques compagnie de danse de france
le bas des français de nancy on a perdu
un chat c'est à dire que je vais très
très souvent ici parce que j'ai pas j'ai
déjà accepté le poste et donc j'ai
décidé de ne pas être un directeur de
fantômes qu'on voit une fois tous les 36
du mois mais effectivement depuis le
départ c'est clair il n'est pas question
je renonce à mes amis engagements
internationaux auxquels le japon et les
etats-unis n'était pas question je
renonce à mes quinze représentations à
l'opéra donc je continue à danser à
l'opéra je continue à faire des grandes
créations avec des chorégraphes comme
maurice béjart djhone meilleur roland
petit mais en même temps tout ce que je
peux à l'extérieur je vais en faire
profiter lancy une des premières choses
que j'ai fait c'est restructurer les
séances de travail que j'ai insisté
vraiment sur la qualité des cours je les
ai rendu obligatoire ce qui est ce qui
est tout à fait bien aussi pour moi
parce que ça m'oblige ça m'oblige à
prendre les pauvres c est surtout sur
tout ce que je veux c'est que les
danseurs qui sont engagés ne soit pas
uniquement là pour me produis enfin
comme commun et les moins productifs
mais surtout que
qu'ils fassent des progrès que
j'ai eu droit à mon premier conseil
d'administration il ya un mois ce qui
était tout à fait impressionnant j'étais
absolument incapable de faire un
discours envie de dire ce que je voulais
faire arrêter de propager des prix
attractifs mais là maintenant je suis
confronté à une structure qui est qui et
nationale complétée pas une seule
seconde par seconde c'est beaucoup plus
risqué maintenant si beaucoup plus
dangereux et c'est un challenge bien
plus important et c'est ça qui me c'est
ça qui m'inspire ce qui m'excite c'est
ça qui me fait plaisir
patrick dupont ont dit encore sa joie de
recommencer à travailler en équipe de
pouvoir enfin faire sécher ses collants
ailleurs que sur des radiateurs d'hôtel
il dit enfin que son ambition est de
faire du ballet de nancy la compagnie
phare de la danse française et pour
conclure nous donne rendez vous à paris
pour une première vraie confrontation
internationale
les monnaies fait les grands